当然总说高考完就松了,毕业以后就好了,工作以后就好了
这是一条全程AI制作品牌方直接定考的国酒软广
我是如何从您制作的呢
今年五月初我接到的这个案子
今天公开我商业制作幕后,先看成片
大家伙加油干, 这个项目做完, 下半天就轻松了
我们的轻松,好像一直都是他们说
咱俩明天还去吗
未有时,必须去
也可以是自己给的
原来轻松这件事,不用等到谁批准
整条片子制作我严格分为五大核心步骤
脚本定位, AI声图, 图声视频, 定制 AI音乐和剪辑合成
这是我的创意阶段就跳出了传统思维
我专门和品牌方沟通
年轻人其实不太喜欢空洞的传品推销
能够戳中情绪的故事才是一个好的广告
品牌方想要达到的轻微薰缓压力
拒绝过度饮酒就日常放空的这种自愈
所以我在脚本设计的时候
就可以把年轻人从小到大的压力
全部铺垫在影片的前半段
说的情节我都反复打磨感受到一些共鸣
至少让我们的目标群体能够看到自己的影子
前半段积攒了所有情绪压力
后半段有一杯微薰的裹酒温柔的和解
完美贴合了品牌方的治愈内核
这也是我认为整条港高最打动人的核心思路
以上就是这条写实商业软广的完整幕后制作逻辑
如果大家想看实材教程欢迎点赞留言
点赞够高的话
我立马更新一期保姆机的实材教学
分享更多有用的信息给各位品牌方和创作者
最后非常感谢路由品牌的信任和支持
我是罐头专注AI商业视觉制作
我们下期再见